Her low freak bitches.
That was,
I was in Costa Rica and fortunately we didn't have those,
but we wanted to rough it and my wife was just like,
yeah,
listen,
I just want to go on in the middle.
We fucking slept under a mosquito net dude wear in the jungle.
I do.
We will put it this way.
We did a zip line tour through the northern part of,
we did the rank rank.
Yeah,
we were right there.
So we're staying under this fucking mosquito net and we have like United States
of America bug spray in like the rain forest and it just laughing at that shit.
It's like,
it's like I'm shooting a pellet gun and the guys get a 44 dude.
It was like,
it was like,
I might as well put a one on two.
I had welts all up and down and he'll bite in the shit out of us.
And I remember like the second day,
um,
this,
these fucking army ants just took over our,
our fucking little,
I don't even know what you'd call it.
There was like these ex patriots had a fucking,
literally this giant tree fort that they lived in,
and then they had these little bungalows so that you had to walk up a ladder to
get into and these fucking things just took over the place and the guy's like
came on and I go,
yeah,
I did.
I came,
I was like,
oh,
there's like a fucking thousand ants in there.
Like they were all in a single file and he just came washed.
He goes,
yeah,
those,
the army ants.
He goes,
yeah,
he just can't do anything about it.
Uh,
was standing there looking at him and I got like,
these flip flops on and he goes,
you can't do anything about,
I'm just,
you just got to let them pass through,
take a couple of hours.
And he goes out,
watch out though.
They bite and write as he said that one of them fucking bit me.
And I was just like,
dude,
you gotta be fucking kidding me.
So,
uh,
so they had a monkey and a spider monkey and pet.
Yup.
Not really a pet.
I mean,
not pet by its choice,
but he hung out.
Yay.
They had it.
No,
they had it as a pet by their choice.
The monkey was was a prisoner.
Oh,
so,
so he's an so I went over there and it's done.
Now it's sitting on top of like,
it looks like a birdhouse silicon asshole.
I walk over to this fucking thing like giving it food and everything and it
fucking jumps on me in two seconds.
It jumped on me inverted,
had its tail wrapped around my neck,
reached into my pockets,
took my bungalow keys and then ran up the fucking tree with the keys to my
bungalow so I couldn't fucking get into it and it all,
it all went down in like fucking like 0.3 seconds and things just went fucking
that was standing there feeling subhuman.
I was like,
I just got out smarter by this thing.
Like this is one for their side and the monkey was up there looking at me.
I know it's fucking laughing at me going like,
oh you dumb mother fuckers.
Keep it right in your right front pocket.
I get it every time.
So then I was sitting there going like,
all right,
all right motherfucker.
Right?
You want to have a battle of wits?
Here we go.
So I get some food,
right?
So I come down and I know I'm judging,
it's fucking leash,
how far it can jump.
So it Kinda get all the way back down on its little fucking bird house,
which was probably about three feet long.
So I'm sitting there walking with the food and it knows I want the key and it's
actually holding the fucking key away from its body and seeing if it can have
its cake and eat it like a fucking human being.
Ooh.
So yeah.
Wow.
So I get the food and when I did was I set it,
I,
I took a big chunk of whatever the fuck it was was,
so we would need two hands.
So it's set down my keys.
So it's set down the keys on the other side of the fucking thing.
And then it was walking,
it was slowly walking towards it and right as it got to the food.
This is why I'm a sadistic Gasol raise the got to the food,
I fucking slapped the food off the house so it would be out of its reach.
And then I grabbed the fucking keys and ran and this thing fucking leapt at me.
I
swear to God,
I swear to God I could feel its breath and I fucking made it away to the other
side of it.
And it was fucking pissed at me and I was standing there.
This is the Middle Costa Rica going,
yeah,
fuck you motherfucker.
Fuck you.
Right.
So here's the funniest part,
right?
So I go into my bungalow and I'm fucking still kind of pissed at that fucking
thing and I go and unlock the door and I'm sitting there for like 20 minutes
reading a book or whatever.
And then I just got on.
I just started thinking about the monkey and I fucking looked out the window and
it was sitting there all by itself looking all sad and everything.
And then I felt bad.
So then I went and I got food and I didn't have my keys this time.
And I actually kind of made friends with the thing after that,
but I felt when I saw it all lonely and she,
I was like,
you know what?
This thing's a prisoner.
It doesn't want to fucking be here and I'm being a dick.
I got to give it to food.
So I gave it back to it.
Yeah.
I felt bad.
That's a happy ending.
The happy.
I felt bad.
I don't get an inmate.
Okay.